the fact that many men fear marriage
because of ending up with someone like
Mia Khalifa is definitely not an
irrational fear the problem is that they
start believing that every woman is like
that which is as irrational as it gets
yeah I think that's kind of what it
comes what it comes down to uh we should
recognize that the young men who are you
know shying away from Marriage that for
a lot of them it's because they see
women like this and they see that the
Instagram video or she's laughing about
divorcing all these men and encouraging
women and saying hey if you're not
feeling fulfilled every second of the
day in your marriage then just leave and
go find somebody else